our first guest has been entertaining us
since she was
three years old throughout her career
she's been a singer a tv host an author
please welcome the incredible icon marie
osmond
[Applause]
i'm so excited to talk to you today
you know drew we are you and i have so
many similarities and there's not many
people who can relate
to the life that we've had um you know
even even all the things that we've been
through so this is super fun
for me to be able to talk to you are you
kidding no you started performing when
you were three
right i was introduced as the youngest
osmond brother
literally
yeah it was on andy williams he we all
kind of got ours our you know shot from
andy uh but you know it's so interesting
you know very much like i have never not
worked uh
a year of
my life since then i've worked
consistently uh whether it was singing
uh you know in sweden and performing
there or doing japanese commercials or
you know whatever it was and i had my my
first hit record i recorded it 12 and a
half paper roses
and at 14 and a half did the pilot for
donny and marie the uh the
original variety show and so and i have
never stopped since and i'm so i feel so
blessed
oh my god i love you
i really really do and
there's a couple aspects about
motherhood that also
really was important for me and i got
excited about talking to you about
i would love to start with your mother
and ask about how
she kept you guys level headed
she you know okay like for example uh
donny and marie okay i was
i believe i was around 16 years old and
i had come home and you know you put
hours in i was doing 15 hours a day 6
days a week sometimes 18 hours
working through the child welfare laws
and going to school and learning 350
pages of script in two and a half days
and i remember one time i came home and
it was the next day was the taping i
said mom i'm so tired i i have to get to
sleep so that i look good on camera and
she goes well you haven't done your
chores
and i said
hello like you know our show has dubbed
into 17 languages worldwide and i'm like
you know marie osmond and
she
that was the worst thing i ever could
have said because she goes oh oh oh i
see so now you're going to do your
chores and the toilets and if you make
another word a complaining i have a lot
more for you to do
and she said because you have to realize
that's a job
jobs will come and go this is reality
this is what will always be here now get
to work and drew throughout my life this
woman
she said i'd come home and she'd say
okay now we're going to learn to make
bread now we're going to learn to make
clothing and i would like mom i have
designers and people that she goes
exactly that's why you're going to learn
to do it and um she just i mean she
taught me how to get a fish in case i
was camping and i needed to cook it this
woman taught me reality my mom told me
when she goes i don't care if you hate
me if you do that means i'm doing a good
job
yes yes
i couldn't agree more and um
something else that has to do with
mothers
that i really loved about your story was
when i had kids of my own
i felt like oh my god i don't want to
pretend to be other people my kids need
me
those 18-hour days
uh
no longer seem like a good idea for me
right now i've been doing them my whole
life so it was i had a luxury of saying
i'm ready to prioritize my children over
work um but then i had to earn a living
so i had to figure stuff out
but
i wanted to find something that felt
like a job that had the hours and being
in the same place
um a lot of the things that our other
jobs did just didn't allow uh the fact
that you have prioritized your children
you'll never regret that i had to do
that with my children too that's one of
the reasons i went to vegas for 11 years
and that was my point is that you found
a job
that put your kids first and when i
heard that it made me feel like i just
it made a lot of sense to me because it
made me feel like hey i made i didn't
make as much on the road when i was
doing all my country uh my country
touring because i took all my kids with
me and i have eight and so uh you know
it's not it's not great for airplane
tickets and costs but i did it because i
love my children also i was the only
breadwinner long story short now
my oldest is she just turned 19 and
she's in she's out of the home so it's
just me and my husband
by the way i remarried my first husband
and so it's like honeymoon all over
again and uh but now i'm i want to go
back out on the road i'm actually
getting ready to do a big symphonic tour
i just did an album a 17 song album um i
was doing my research and i was learning
about you and steve
um and i
marvel at your story you guys um
married in 82
and then
separated in 85. i don't have a monitor
i was born exactly
um and then
you remarried in 2011. am i getting the
years right
a few okay good um
i love this so much i can't even stand
it first of all is that really the same
wedding dress
it is it's the same dress with some
laces in the back to make it a little
bigger
i was just curious like
how did you guys refine each other well
if you ask him he was asked the other
day how do you make a marriage work and
he said spend 25 years apart
[Laughter]
it worked
you know we we were always best friends
but i think so really we didn't even
plan it it was just so bizarre how it
happened uh i had moved to vegas and uh
we had one child together our our oldest
son stephen i said stephen can you help
me move some things in
and my my son said well dad's with me
can he come help and
my uh
he had never remarried
and uh i i guess i'm a hard habit to
break
no
but we when we saw each other i don't
know i think you have to realize people
change but some things don't change
like the friendship we we were just soul
mates we always had that connection
seriously okay do i hear crazy i don't
know if we have time for this but um
that wedding dress
i was married 20 years i had no idea
where that dress was i had moved several
times i had moved to vegas
i didn't pack that dress for vegas and i
had designed a dress for our wedding and
five days before the wedding the lady
showed up with it in 75 000 pieces and i
had my cry and i'm not kidding you guys
i walked out to the car to go to work uh
and there was a box leaning on my car
an old box and i looked and it was my
way i'm gonna cry it was my wearing
dress
crazy
to this day i still don't know where
that dress showed up from and i swear
was my mom i swear
[Music]